a third of new arrivals die within 3
years while their masters Grow Rich and
build grand Mansions overlooking the
Damned the Central Square in image must
be the Master's house the rectangular
structures we saw in the ground that
must be the barck blocks to accommodate
the
slaves this would have been a central
Mill here where the cane was crushed and
the juice come down into refining
furnaces a counts of sugar boiling
houses depict a steaming vision of
hell where copper cauldrons of raw syrup
Bubble at
240°
Fahrenheit it would have been incredibly
hot smoke would have been toxic hell
hole down in this in this Mill